alors là vous avez eue dans votre vie
des hauts et des bas comme tout le monde
et on va faire une interview à peine
d'armes
ça arrive ce que vous préférez en vous
ma ba ma chance la chance que j'ai ouais
c'est pas en moi c'est je suis né sur
une bonne source d'une bonne étoile et
une chance folle toute ma vie vous voyez
pas été plus heureux si vous aviez vécu
au caire finalement avec faten hamama il
en est dans une star cairote en étant
une star égyptienne c'est possible je ne
le saurai jamais je ne serai jamais ce
qui serait arrivé si on m'avait pas pris
pour lawrence d'arabie
il est fort possible que j'aurais été
plus heureux dans ma vie oui parce que
vous savez aussi fait pas comme ça dans
une chambre docteur il dit gosse je leur
épingle par un trial famille patrie
alors ça ce que vous haïssez en vous je
n'ai rien en moi parce que quand je fais
quelque chose je l'aï c'est quelque
chose en moi je ferai de tous pour
corriger cette chose que j'ai d'ailleurs
plus beaucoup de fric à c'était à 66
fric
j'ai gagné un million $ au casino parce
que j'étais avec une gt dans nord de
l'italie 1 et avait une starlette qui
était assise à côté de moi qui étais
très très bien
on est allé à la discothèque on a flirté
tout pigé dit de monter avec moi si elle
voulait bien prendre un verre dans ma
chambre
là tu m'as dit non je te fous de rage et
j'avais bu pas mal je suis allée au
casino il j'ai joué le numéro que je ne
joue jamais c'est à dire le 29 à la
roulette et ses sorties 4 x 2 froyo
dévaliser la banque mais c'est alors le
lendemain j'ai acheté toutes les fleurs
d'interflora et j'ai envoyé un camion
parce que tu es allé à rome
j'aurai un camion de fleurs à cette
jeune dame qui était dans le nord qui
t'a fait 2,5 tonnes 5 tonnes de fleurs
crise cardiaque elle est membre
bâle est devenu florissant du retour des
pyrénées
vinet résine et inélégamment une carte
qui disait vous auriez été le coup le
plus cher de ma vie le plus grosses
pertes c'est quand vous êtes obligés de
vendre ou de votre appartement
oui oui j'ai aussi c'était dans ces
heures d'avancé sommes là c'était tout
l'argent que possédait au monde à ce
moment là on board ken block le plus
grand moment de votre vie difficile le
plus grand moment j'ai peut-être chez
pas la naissance mon fils juin et
probablement que j'adore mon fils je
suis vraiment aux fanatiques de mon fils
est la mienne aussi
le pire moment le plus je ne sais pas
c'est là c'est tous les moments de
déchéance physique quand quand on est
malade et les nerfs doivent s'occuper de
vous et vous accompagne et à la salle de
bains de la fin et c'est des moments
atroces
j'étais malade boucher j'ai eu et j'ai
fait un potager eu à une hanche et
changé une enfin une prothèse j'ai une
prothèse douchez n'est plus là non je
suis même pas à manger avec les hôtesses
des fous à lui un miracle pour fumer
parce que je fumais 100 cigarettes par
jour et un jour j'ai eu mal à la
poitrine et j'ai compris que cette
écriture de cardiaque
alors comme je ne savais pas qui parle
et j'ai regardé plafond et je lui ai
parlé je dis que je n'ai jamais parlé
avant de te dire maintenant si tu me
fais vivre jusqu'à demain matin j'arrête
de fumer
bon et puis j'ai arrêté puis j'ai repris
une cigarette pour rallumer j'ai eu un
choc électrique
et quand j'ai mise dans ma bouche j'ai
été très malade j'ai vomi j'ai eu des
osez terrible et depuis je n'ai plus pu
toucher une cigarette
vous arrivez alors je lui ai plus jamais
parler j'attends
c'est l émulsion notre l'odieux peu plus
belles histoires d'amour s'est faite un
moment j'imagine oui sûrement un succès
massif et puis tous les autres qui sont
marqués sophie davant evelyne dhéliat
marie ange nardi oui la plus minable
marie-ange larruy vous savez qu'elle a
elle même
allez zou quand elle était à la pyramide
qu'elle faisait la malle et hamida sur
le réduire mais s'il ya une question sur
moi 1
donc on a dix qui est à jouer docteur
lui avoir trucs comme ça
elle n'a pas su répondre quelque et
après on l'a dit mais c'est omar sharif
bien sûr elle a dit mais j'ai jamais
entendu parler voilà alors tu n'as rien
tu avais une aventure avec elle 82
marché c'est pas comme sophie davant
bien alors votre vote vous de plus
minables histoire d'amour
tiens il a été avec rita hayworth non
oui c'était j'ai eu une aventure pu
m'occuper fientes avec elle je
l'admirais beaucoup depuis que j'étais
très jeune et un soir elle était elle
avait assez bu et je les raccompagner
chez elle habitait sur les hauts de
canet ont tourné un film ensemble et moi
j'habitais à nice et quand on est arrivé
elle m'a dit ce que vous voulez prendre
un verre je descends en avait une
voiture d'à production les cas chauffeur
je vais avec elle elle avait un bar qui
étaient en bas m'a dit vous aimez le vin
blanc j'ai compris que ce qu'elle
voulait que je bois est prêt à verre de
vin blanc de r et puis on a flirté en la
flore tu es très bientôt
et puis au moment où on était au point
de point culminant de notre relation
elle me dit mais vous croyez que vous
allez me sauter vous je suis qui n ont
jamais patron fait qu'il aurait un jour
hamas mais je vois que tu habites qui
était partout jours ski joëring jeter
mais qu elle me dit allez sortez vous
êtes une concret et que vous êtes arrivé
vous allez tourner un film avec hollande
d'arabie vous avez laissé jusqu'à oui
mais elle était sous la peau est
normalisée bref elle me dit sortez alain
je sors et a pas la voiture
alors lui mais où est la voiture munie
de renvoyer marché et jeu et j'ai fait
de l'auto-stop à 5 heures du matin
on va garder halak devait aussi un crime
elle elle était adorable c'est aimer
vraiment vraiment ma copine si vous
préférez dans le sexe les préliminaires
là c'était le cas c'est très content
qu'elle met viré avant pour traiter ce
qui vous dégoûte le plus dans le sexe de
l'après sexe quand ça se passe mal
1 quand quand on se retourne chacun de
son côté constat au 1 étape ou qu'on
doive se rhabiller partir un tas france
les cas pas de bagnole